good morning Hank it's Friday I woke up
early yesterday with nothing to do but
write and thought I think I might just
go to Belgium today so I walked down to
Amsterdam Central Station and bought a
ticket on the slow train to Antwerp I
wanted time away from the internet and
my life time to write Hey watching
people write is boring in my case at
least it doesn't even involve that much
typing but writing does at least for me
require quite a lot of concentration and
to concentrate you must be prepared to
face the terrifying specter of boredom
without fear in that respect at least
both the reading and writing of books
have become kind of countercultural
activities in the social media era books
don't lend themselves to multitasking
they don't automatically update and as
much as I love the Internet I'm happiest
when I'm writing got into an fort
knowing nothing about the city except
that there are winkles to the left and
winkles to the right and emerge from the
train station into this Central Square
my general strategy for visiting a place
I haven't done any research about is
just to find someone who looks like a
tourist and follow them to wherever
they're going because I figure they did
the research for me then I just stop at
any old buildings and or zoos this dude
had a guide book in his pocket so I
followed them and sure enough they led
me to two sweet old buildings although
neither was open so I returned to the
train station to find more tourists to
stalk whereupon I noticed holy crap
there's the zoo at the zoo I saw little
monkeys and big monkeys and swingy
monkeys and this monkey with pants
picking up sticks for the presumed
purpose of building a nest and this
monkey with pants planting ferns in some
kind of primitive experiment in
agriculture and almost puppy-sized
elephants and tigers and zebra giraffe
horses and this penguin that appeared to
be decapitated but was in fact just
sleeping and badass fish and a shark
chatting with a seahorse okay that was
on television and this tortoise I tried
to tell him that it needed to go on and
brush his shoulder off on account of how
his shoulder appeared to be storing the
fecal matter of a different tortoise but
he either didn't understand me or he was
making a fashion statement
I also saw these giraffes who were
separated for me only by an ankle high
fence and a tiny water fountain Hank I
filmed them for like 10 minutes and they
kept looking at me like no matter how
long you leave that camera on we are not
going to mount each other then I went
back to the station where I wrote the
world's coolest escalator up and then
straight and up the
and how are these miraculous escalators
only in Belgium did the Belgians
patented them we must press this
technology from their tiny poly lingual
hands minutes later at my train platform
I learned that my train was off the
shaft and I was like I hope that doesn't
mean delayed since everyone is leaving I
think that was bad
it means abolished but another train
came an hour later and I wrote all the
way home and that Hank is how I lived
for a day without the internet I'll see
you on Monday